hey folks hey let's just uh we'll give
it to her at the 30-second mark and then
we'll talk then we'll get a little talk
a little bit more give a couple minutes
yeah cumulate into the room the
30-second mark lets's would almost there
yeah almost up hello hello welcome to
the live Pat okay so um we experimented
with YouTube's live live stream chat
picked a pretty poor tonight whoever
picked the worst time to experiment with
the live stream chat yeah but what we
noticed was there's a lot of comments
coming like the video itself that we did
had like a lot more likes and dislikes
but we did pay attention to the comments
of what happened in the video we were
talking about why Zack Snyder left
Justice League Joss Whedon was taking
over we did a couple things in
consideration I have a habit of I have a
habit of like when I title videos I just
put exclamation marks at the end it's
just a YouTube thing to do and that came
across a that came across the wrong way
that came across as if we're being
insensitive and that we're making this
sound like it's super exciting news
yeah and so and that was a wrong
approach to take this and the second
thing was that people were a lot of
people were commenting as if we were
being very insensitive or disrespectful
or basically they think that making
jokes about the news which we never
actually did but you know we the tone of
the video still we didn't get to talking
about the topic until about three
minutes into the video you know we had
some intro stuff you know we had our
general BAM turbot to get things going
yeah cuz Dagon
it probably just wasn't the best idea
and so the last thing we wanted to do
too was film a video edited up to make
it seem like some kind of [ __ ] you
know response yeah the response that we
were receiving so we're like we'll just
go live and let you guys know like
suckers exactly what happened
and so hey I wanna I do want to
apologize I did put out a tweet saying
that we did take the video down yeah
because even though we re watch the
whole video before we took it down yes
make sure we didn't we didn't slip and
say anything totally off-color or
something like that yeah exactly and and
and I know that when we address the
serious part of the video about what
happened with Zack Snyder's family that
I know we weren't being insensitive and
we touched on it for about a couple
minutes saying how serious and how
devastating it was I've lost family
members in my life and I know how how
devastating that can be used what I've
said a lot of people friends lost to
suicide or early struggle very much we
yet yeah and but I know that the overall
tone of the video that I think the
problem that we encountered was that you
know because it's our first time going
live and because we're live and people
know us for being you know like trying
to keep things at least entertaining a
little bit we wanted to we we know the
overall video didn't have a tone that
resembled that you know we we took the
the news to a serious wait we didn't we
didn't take it to we did we didn't come
across at all like we actually
understood the the real tragedy behind
it we started going Weibull we started
going way more into you know the idea of
joss whedon taking over the idea what
joss whedon could be doing and what this
means for DCE you instead of staying
more on point with what happened with
Zack Snyder but we felt we were honestly
thinking this probably wouldn't be our
arena to really touch on this probably
wouldn't be our arena to explore of what
happened here with in terms of the
tragedy aspect but because we know that
I have a 12-minute video we only touched
on that for a couple minutes yeah so we
do want to apologize to anyone who did
take offense thinking that we didn't
understand the the gravity of the
situation here yeah this is pretty
shocking no to be honest like this you
don't hear this a lot and this is the
first time we I think we've ever had
there's been like a tragedy like this to
address in our
fear yeah like a like a video that we
would do yeah yeah exactly so we'll open
this up to comments and stuff and see
you know what people say and if you just
so you know if you guys right like mean
things if there's a simple button here
where I could just block you guys I mean
if I if I want to it's easy to get
tone-deaf by accident like it lay out
like it is it's easy to be caught up in
stuff and just to take the wrong
approach and you know it's different our
side too yeah you're on a camera and and
you know we're live and is that we're
not used to being live yeah so it was a
different experience for that but you
know and let's just let's just see
what's going on here let's just the
communities are what how do we hope
Natalie comments I don't know if you can
like if you do Facebook live you can
scroll back through but yeah this before
yeah cuz I don't think I I really don't
think we were being insensitive to when
we were touching on the serious topic
yeah the actual and I mean it's you can
say it again I mean that's that's
arguably now I was shocked when I saw
the headline and and I'm glad that he's
stepping away because that's where you
should be his with your family like I
understand he said like getting back to
work might be just the thing but but you
know yeah there's there's I don't think
there's anything that can help you get
over things well the I think the I think
the average response for anyone who I
see grieving through something whether
it be a death or even like a long-term
relationship breakup I think what most
people do or a lot of people some people
either stay really depressed and let
that sink in sometimes they wallow or
sometimes I just take the time to really
grieve but then a lot of people take the
other approach to which is they throw
themselves into work and I think the
death of his daughter came around the
time of March and so he has been working
on the film actively but we also said in
the previous video that it's it's best
that he takes a step back because family
comes first
grieving is necessary when these movies
are huge and they got to be
all-consuming yeah like it this only
happened a little over a month ago and I
can't imagine
anybody's okay yeah I can't I can't
imagine being in Zack Snyder's position
that's what I can't imagine is someone
who has who's coming off these DC films
and there's all this pressure already
just for a movie there's already all
this weight and pressure of a movie and
then he has this terrible tragedy happen
with his family his daughter passes away
and I can imagine the crossroads you're
kind of at but I can't really fathom
what the crossroads are like to be at
such a thing of men there's all this
pressure for this movie that I signed on
to and there's and there's all this
anticipation and fan convoy fans are
very dedicated but you know he has his
own life too he has his own family he
has 10 to 2 he's got his wife he's got
his other children so I'm all in support
of him leaving the project letting Joss
Whedon finish up whatever
post-production stuff that is left on
the film because Joss Whedon's great
Kent is a great person to finish up
whatever touches that needed to be made
on Justice League
1 on the on the movie side of that I
think of all the people who you could
hand this off to I think Joss Whedon is
is a is a safe pair of hands you know
classes and honestly like that that was
forget the movie there was just that
read is a nice thing to me that Joss
Whedon would step up and and take over
for him because you know not a lot of
people can fill that role and and you
know to open the door for it for him to
go and have some family time this is a
great thing for does we to do all right
so let's well pay attention to a few
more comments now after we explained our
side of things so once again apology so
he thought we were being insensitive
about it because we understand I know
not everyone thinks that I know a lot of
people think that we weren't being
insensitive or some people were
defending us in comments but at the same
time we totally understood why people
might have gotten that impression
yeah of that but that's what it was was
an impression of it it wasn't in fact or
an actually an actual truth as to our
side of the spectrum here so you start
out you get tone-deaf a little bit and
then you learn yeah and then you don't
then you hear that tone from this guy's
an interesting names you bagged nine
nine eight he was
talk it's been a crazy day first off
there was a incident in Manchester yeah
ariana grande and then this happens and
like it's just it's kind of a dark heavy
day yeah it really is and I can imagine
you know like first off if you're in the
comments too because I could see people
commenting right now even on this
livestream talking about how you know
people are just being overly sensitive
and whatnot I don't think that's a fair
thing to say to people you know I don't
think it's a fair thing to say because
it's a sensitive time you know yeah and
everyone was even if it even if they
don't personally know anyone that
happened at the Manchester incident even
if they don't personally know Zack
Snyder or a sunburn eller or Chris
Cornell all these terrible things that
have been happening recently in the
media that we've been learning about
everyone still responds to the news of
death very differently some people are
detached from it some people because
they've experienced death in their life
relate to it and then arch and then have
emotions brought up to it that could
also be playing a factor in it so some
people you know to call people
insensitive or sensitive it just depends
you know it is when there's death on the
table I feel like you just should I
don't feel like it's a very worthwhile
conversation to figure out who's being
too or too sensitive not sensitive
enough you guys can argue about yeah but
yeah I mean everybody processes these
kinds of things differently and they
always make you think about human life
you know like you have to confront death
at some point for a lot of us like you
have to at least confront the presence
of suicide in your life you know like a
lot of people will come into contact
with that yeah um I lost my train of
thought but but uh yeah I don't know I
mean I don't think you can be too
sensitive about something like this and
it's you know when something happened
you know if somebody's tone-deaf about
it yeah it's fair yeah I get it or or
you know if there's a concern that was
like when we first posted the video even
it was that was my first concern was
like oh no is did we handle this wrong
way like
you know remind me to block this Jason
end guy who's commenting nobody in this
chat seems to be on the outside nobody
likes this Jason guy especially with you
because he's just attacking people and
thank God for YouTube's able to block
people thing that they added a little
button to because sidelines do yeah dude
God there will always be trolls but hat
you know you're gonna keep going like
this life matter come on yeah hey Luce
oh we love you too I love you too but
yeah these guys have any questions or
anything else you want us to clarify on
we could talk about it yeah you can talk
about we're only gonna be here for a
couple more minutes I gotta get to
editing yeah
listen yeah it's just just to address
that I guess was all ticking by it's
cool - there was a - couple arguments
about this big yeah it's cool to dislike
movies and stuff like that but uh you
know movies or and the people who make
them or to separate things and so
something happens in that person's life
it doesn't matter what you think of
Justice League cuz ultimately Justice
League it doesn't truly matter and
that's why his ex Nider left to go be
with his band yeah yeah we said it in
the first thing we filmed in the first
stream we did that we have like no issue
with him leaving to do it and not one
comment was we don't like Zack Snyder as
a director this is better that Joss
Whedon's doing this and he's gonna
change the fact that what that wasn't
that didn't even come close to anything
we said in order I think I think like
one person really thought that's what we
were saying because that wasn't that's
not at all what we felt you know when we
when John told me John found this
article and then John told me about it
like one of my first words were man I
feel bad for any time we clowned on Zack
Snyder yes those the thing is I admit
like I saw the headline like Zack Snyder
though the first thing I saw was a tweet
was like I feel really bad Zack Snyder I
was like why you know and I first
checked this out and and you know like
if you told me with no context if I just
heard Oh Zack Snyder's stepping back I
would've been like
here's more drunk yeah you know and
maybe I'd like you like you said we've
we've bagged on the ex nighters movies
here and there but reading that article
I wasn't even thinking about Justice
League like like I said Justice League
doesn't actually matter it's fake it's
not real uh you know this guy lost his
daughter the guy lost his daughter which
is not an experience every person gets
now and and apt and seriously like I I
mean if I found that if if how pretty
here exactly know about Zack Snyder
losing his daughter this happened in
March and one I don't know I never heard
about that well this only came out as
far any article I could find when I
found it they were only like an hour -
oh I think they were gonna keep I didn't
think they wanted to to put this
information out and it seemed like did
the one that quote sorry basically said
like we weren't we were initially not
gonna talk about this yeah but we feel
like we have to well it because that
would be they have to explain he has to
explain why he's leaving and I
appreciate the honesty because that's
not an easy thing to make public yeah
it's not easy it's not an easy thing to
just let the world because the world is
going to hear about this
the world's going to hear about the loss
of your daughter and this hoarding this
horrible way and it's not an easy
decision but I understand though why he
said it cuz he has to make it clear one
honest I watch me we're gonna speculate
a bunch of billion different other false
reasons as to why he left you yeah and I
and ultimately sadly I do think that
that is something that is we should take
a look at just everybody should take a
look at in the way in how serious we
take this kind of stuff and with what
big a deal we make out of it because II
yeah I almost feel like they shouldn't
have to say anything but if he said
nothing I'm sure there would just be a
hailstorm like blah
do you see Starks and Zack Snyder must
be a terrible Phyllis Lee might be
terrible that's why they fired him yeah
people would assume all the wrong
reasons so you have to reveal the truth
of what actually happened yeah and I and
I almost feel like that's the one way
for them to get a little peace and
you know in a big broad con it's like
it's in the air right now it's like we
had what what happened with Chris
Cornell last week and now this like
there's uh in an odd way saying it now
might help the conversation at least
because the thing is like Chris Cornell
passing last week like that is open up
I've seen so many arguments about the
topic of suicide and and some people
being like ah coward and you know people
with hearts being like no yeah that's
not how that works you know so um what I
just hope that this could maybe improve
the conversation yeah but yeah I mean
all the I really feel for Zack Snyder I
mean I feel terrible for him for his
whole family that's like he and his wife
like they produced these movies like did
this is their business and you know to
step back and take some family time is
absolutely thing obsolete um yeah so
that's why we took on the video guys and
that's why I took down the video because
despite the fact that not everyone felt
out that way about it we understood that
the the percentage of people that did
feel that way we felt bad that that was
what was communicating and we're not
going to put the blame on anyone's
reaction to how we came across in that
video we're not going to get blamed on
them we understand that because of how
the overall tone of the video was coming
across that that there was a percentage
of people who were taking offense and to
it so last thing we want to do is go
you're being too sensitive yeah
understood you know we felt bad we felt
like really bad like [ __ ] this isn't
even accurately portraying the actual
mood that it was creating for us yeah we
were looking back and you know we were
like could it be this could it be this
and then we were and then it finally
kind of set it on the both of us like
you know maybe this was kind of a mess
let's just do it again
yeah just let's just address them he
came and if he and we said at the
beginning of the live stream the reason
we went live is so we can just not
[ __ ] you guys we don't want to like
record it and be like well we really
thought about a response to what to say
yeah it's like
just be honest Finn's not make it though
Japan yeah yeah let's just be honest
about how what the [ __ ] we did and why
we felt bad about it and you know if I
get if you know just to take em on I'm
sure some people are gonna think this is
cheesy but you know it always bears
repeating if you need help
always talk to somebody like somebody
their numbers you can call their people
you can reach out to and it's always
better to reach them to not do yeah even
when you don't feel like that like you
can I mean this happened with me several
years ago I know it was like planning on
revealing this stuff but John was around
for a very specific moment in my life
about four five years ago this is before
the channel this is this is free YouTube
pretty YouTube where I got admitted to
the hospital a couple of times one for a
actually whap this feels very it's
uncomfortable to say because I was
having a suicidal ideations and there
was one specific attempt that I took and
he has about five six years ago when
this happened this is definitely before
YouTube it was like it was like a little
bit before YouTube before we even
started uploading videos and I had to go
through a crazy journey on it I've had
and that was around the time when I was
experiencing a lot of deaths in my
family there were a lot of deaths
happening in my family dad and grandma
passed away ten days apart and it was
especially tough year for me I have no
idea as to why zack snyder's daughter
did what she did
I know it's like it's it's it's it's
weird
it is flat-out it's just weird to
receive news as to why someone committed
suicide as to the fact that someone
could what the action was that they
committed suicide but to not really have
the context us through the possibility
as to why they did it and then people
start speculating on it which I'm sure
which which from reading some live
stream comments already of nasty jabs
they're taking as to why she did it
don't even yeah
don't even touch that yeah there are
people I see in comment I see comments
already people I won't even repeat some
of the things that people have been
saying there's as to why she did it to
him from there I gosh but yeah like it's
as bad oh yeah
and someone just pointed out happy John
was there sorry the comments are going
so fast yeah John was really there there
was one time I remember cleaving John
and message or send an email I have that
same an email and I rejoice only John
was at my place and yeah that was a dark
period for me I remember that yeah so
it's so the only reason I'm revealing
that the only reason I'm taking I don't
I take every once in a while very rare
but wherever he wants in a while I'll
take the time to reveal something a
little personal about my life
experiences and I don't think I've ever
revealed that on the Internet of what I
was doing many years ago and the owners
that I'm reviewing that is because I I
don't I'm letting you know like I don't
think lightly of this situation that
actually happened oh just so you yeah
yeah I'm using only reason why as a
clinically depressed person yeah I can
yeah i if this came across light at any
point I was certainly not not the
intention because uh you know we already
don't know enough about mental science
yes as a cult just as a you know has a
broad range society I mean you know the
Greg and I both kind of jumped pretty
pretty deep into you know that but um
yeah it's see this guy I'm not gonna
read what he said no this is guy ancient
internet troll who just left a really
mean comment about um what life is that
I yeah I don't even know how you have
some people have them the nerve to do
that
yeah you look hot even if it's a comment
it's just a comment from their YouTube
account like to put it out there to
provoke people as is crazy to me yeah
I'm it's like I don't know at a certain
point way what are you contributing here
with with the joke that makes YouTube
the Internet
so yeah anytime Indian unless from
people on online there are always people
wrench okay keeping your sensitivity
tempered yeah it's alright but yeah you
know enjoy like you know if you need to
make a shallow joke I hope it's good for
you cuz it's not great for the rest of
the world yeah it's not great for you
know humanity and again Justice League
is not important in this context it
doesn't matter
it's a fantasy it who cares what anybody
would have thought about it you know
there's one less person in the world you
know who had a whole life out of them
yeah so who gives a [ __ ] about Justice
League you know alright guys well uh
we're gonna call it a day right now I'm
gonna get to editing we're do know I'm
not gonna plug anything ever do no those
are all habits yeah I think that's led
to a lot of this crap that that we did
that we did on our end that was not
taken well because you know like putting
putting like exclamation marks at the
end of a title is communicates totally
differently than if you don't have
exclamation marks in the title it's a
habit for me to just put that there in a
title or doing an outro where you plug a
couple things like I was about to do
that had a habit you know but I guess on
my end I need to be more mindful and I
need to be it all be more yeah we could
all be I did never stop improving your
mindfulness you can never stop improving
that and I should at that moment I
probably probably will should have been
more mindful as to how the overall tone
of the video is coming across but
prayers for Zack Snyder and his whole
entire family I know he's got he has
more than that one daughter as other
children as well he has got a wife too
10 - and so prayers really go out to him
hopefully there's more of like what Eggs
Benedict Cumberbatch's saying is like
the prayers and the love for Snyder's
family than a bunch of mean troll
comments one and you know people
reaching out to each other you know
would would be a nice thing yeah yeah
and just so you know no one W and just
so you know no one pressured us into
explaining ourselves this was yeah this
just felt like the way to dislike
way to do it because we we saw the
response of a certain percentage of
people and we were like you know I feel
bad it might not be the majority of how
people are responding but that but just
that percentage there enough was to make
us go you know we're [ __ ] we're human
beings to do we're human beings and
we're not like insensitive to people
sensitivity either so yeah we're human
beings and even though this news doesn't
really affect our lives directly you
know like it does it does you know it's
it's important that you handle it the
right way
and you know absolutely do you do right
by it
yeah you you handle with care and yeah
alright we'll let you guys go I'll we'll
sit we'll talk to you guys soon I have
more videos coming up continuing to
channel love you guys to everyone who
joined it on here much love